(dramatic sibilant music)
- Hello Believe Nation.
My name is Evan Carmichael.
My one word is believe and
I believe that entrepreneurs
are going to solve all the
major problems of the world.
So to help you on your path,
in today's video we're going
to talk about seven ways
to manage negative people at work.
And, as always guys, as
you're listening if you hear
something that really resonates with you,
please leave it down
in the Comments below.
Put quotes around it so other people
can be inspired as well.
And when you write it down,
it's much more likely to stick
with yourself too.
Enjoy.
- [Robot] Nine,
eight.
(hiphop music)
- So one of the most
difficult things about being
in a work environment is
being around negative people.
I think even just in home and in general,
being around negative
people sucks and being able
to navigate around and with
those people can sometimes
be important on your journey.
And so today I'm going to share with you
seven different ways to do it
that I hope will inspire you
and help you on your path.
(short percussion music)
My number one way to manage
negative people is don't.
Don't be around negative people.
Eliminate them from your life.
This is what I try to do as
much as possible in my own life.
This may not be the answer
that you're looking for
and there's more that are
coming but it's my best answer
because if you are surrounded
by negative people constantly
you're going to get more negative,
you're going to be unhappy,
you're not going to reach your potential.
And so if I was in a work
environment and this person
was really negative and
being around me all the time,
I might try to transfer,
I might look for other opportunities,
I might even look at a different company,
or maybe even leaving and
starting my own business
and being an entrepreneur.
If you are an entrepreneur
and you have negative people
on your team, then that's
an easier decision.
If somebody is really
skilled and does a great job
but they're negative, they have to go.
You cannot be surrounded
by negative people
because they don't only bring you down,
they'll bring everybody
else around you down.
And so you need to have people
who are positive who are
excited about the project
that you're trying to build.
(short percussion music)
My number two technique for
managing negative people
is to limit your exposure.
So if you are forced to
deal with negative people,
I would try to limit how
much exposure I have to them.
How much time I have to
spend with them would be
at the bare minimum, just
to get whatever project
I'm trying to do and get it done.
And so the first two points
are pretty negative, right?
It's avoid them, have zero exposure.
The second one is to limit
your exposure and why?
You know, if I'm thinking,
well, I want to be a positive influence,
I want to help them, I
want to build them up.
Yes, that's definitely a possibility.
The reason why I start with
the negative is because
the opportunity cost is so great.
For you to spend your
time managing somebody
who is negative, they will
eat up so much of your time
and emotional capital and drain you,
because they're so different than you,
and getting them to the
place where they can be happy
is such a big journey that
you could spend that time
helping 10 other people.
And so I've always
experienced that the people
who are negative take the
most work to turn around
and usually it's not worth
your time compared to
the other people who you could be helping.
So that's why my first two
are really negative around
not being around them at all
or limiting your exposure.
(short percussion music)
Alright, now let's jump
to the positive side.
Number three is be an inspiration.
So, we have to around
these negative people,
we have no other option,
they're super important
and we want to be the force for good.
You can be an inspiration
to build people up.
And so I think of when
women first get together
in an office setting an
eventually their periods
start to align together.
That kind of happens with everything.
If you are around toxic people,
you're more likely to be
toxic on an ongoing basis.
If you're around people who
are working out all the time,
you're more likely to want to work out
and take care of yourself.
If you're around complainers,
you're going to start complaining more.
And so you become your environment.
So if you have that awareness,
you can be an inspiration for that person.
By them just being around you,
you are going to pull them up.
I used to volunteer at a
hospital, Sunnybrook Hospital
here in Toronto, and one of
my shifts was with this woman
who was in charge of
the phones on her floor.
And she would also pick
up the phone in kind of
very angry way.
It was, C2 Laura, C2 Laura.
It was kind of very angry
and it was kind of against
how I would do things and just
the vibe I wanted to put out.
And by spending more
and more time with her,
eventually she got more positive.
She said, C2 Laura, C2
this is Laura speaking.
And it slowly got more and more
and more and more positive.
Now, as I left Sunnybrook,
as my volunteer shift ended,
I don't know if that
continued or if she fell back
to her usual path, but
expect that to happen.
You know, the more they are around you,
I want you to be a force for good, right?
When you find your one
word, whatever that is,
that exudes out of you in
every situation that you go to.
So if you are around me for
any consistent period of time,
even from watching the videos,
you're going to believe harder,
you're going to believe
stronger in yourself,
in your ideas, in the people around you
because that's what I'm all about.
You can't be in my circle
and not gain a little bit more belief.
It's just going to happen.
So that should be you with
your one word getting out there
and being an inspiration for people.
The danger is that, as I said,
two people tend to come together,
the danger is that you become
more toxic and you become
more negative so you need
to have enough other stuff
in your environment that
keeps you at a high level
that pulls them you instead
of you going to them.
(short percussion music)
- Tip number four is to come
from a place of understanding.
I think a lot of people's
negativity is actually
deeply rooted into something else beyond
what they're complaining about.
So I had a situation with a
negative person on my team.
They were constantly putting others down.
They were constantly paranoid
about what the company's
situation was going to be like.
And they were also gossiping
a lot and spreading rumors.
And every single day he would complain.
I would ask him how his
day's going and he would
just say it's terrible.
And it got to a point that
it was actually starting
to make me feel negative
about my situation at work.
And then finally I had to have
a sit down conversation with him.
I wanted to find out why
he was being so negative.
Then he revealed to me
that he was paranoid
of losing his job.
He would wake up every morning
with a fear that he won't
be able to feed his family,
he will not be able to go
on that vacation that
he promised his wife.
Although I wasn't able to
promise him the job security
that he wanted, I was able to
provide him with the security
and safety that he had someone at work
that he could confide in.
And little by little, I
started to see more positivity
come out of him, especially towards me,
which made my life at work a lot easier.
So the next time you come
across someone negative,
before you write them off,
try to come from a place of understanding.
(short percussion music)
- Number five is figure out their dream.
I like to say that one of
the most dangerous things
that you can do is tell
me what your dream is.
If I know what your dream is
then I am always thinking about
how do I help this person at
this thing that they want to do
and pushing you to get
past those limited beliefs
and the negative mindsets to
help you go off and accomplish
your big thing.
And so even the most negative
person has some kind of dream.
They may not feel it's possible,
they may feel like the
world's against them and that
people are conspiring to keep them down
but somewhere deep down
inside they have a dream
of something that they wan to accomplish.
And so if you can figure
out what their dream is,
and then find ways to
help them accomplish it,
be their friend, be their
accountability partner,
give them some resources,
give them some motivational boosts,
share things with them
to help them lift up
and get towards that goal,
then it's really hard
to be making progress towards your dream
and being negative and
unhappy at the same time.
And so guiding them along
that path and encouraging them
will help turn that tide
and turn them from being
super negative to more positive.
(short percussion music)
Number six is recognize
their good behavior.
This is basic parenting
skills or if you are trying to
train a dog, it's kind of the same thing.
You have two options.
You either punish their bad behavior
or you recognize their good behavior.
And you may not be in a
position to punish them
for their bad behaviors and it may be
actually what they want
because they seek the attention
and they love going to a negative place.
And so if I was dealing
with that kind of person,
I had to deal with them,
then I'd be looking at
the negative stuff I'm
just going to ignore
and anytime there is something
positive that they do for me
or the mindset that they have
or something that they shared
that was happy, or funny, or positive,
I would go all in on
encouraging that and thank them
and appreciate them.
Not in a fake way.
Not in a way that they see,
obviously, right through
but in the genuine way
of you really connecting
to that thing that they did
for you and thanking them,
maybe buying them a little
cupcake or something
as a show of appreciation.
Because negative people
aren't surrounded by a lot
of positivity in general.
It's how the become so negative.
And so buy you recognizing
the good deeds that they did,
giving them some appreciation,
giving them some rewards,
they're going to want to do
it again and again and again
and lift out of that negativity.
(short percussion music)
And my number seven way to
deal with negative people
is help them find a happier place.
Quite often, negative
people are so bummed out
by their position, by their work,
they're not passionate about it anymore,
they don't, you know, have
the desire to be there anymore
and everybody would be
happier if they moved on.
It kind of ties a little
bit into understanding
what their dream is because
often if they have a dream
and they're doing something
totally different,
then they're going to
be negative and unhappy.
They're going to see
other people who are off
accomplishing these
great things in the field
that they want to be in and
they're stuck in this job
that they hate.
And so helping push them
to follow that dream,
find a happier place,
go pursue that passion,
is great for them because they're happier,
they're off doing the thing that they need
and sometimes they just
need a little bit of a push.
And it's great for you because
now you don't have to deal
with this negative person in
your work environment anymore.
So those are my top seven ways
on how to manage negative people at work.
I'd love to know what did you guys think?
What was your favorite one?
Which one really hit home?
What can you apply to your business
or maybe your life immediately?
Leave it down in Comments below.
Did I miss an eight, nine,
10 that you guys want to add
to the list?
I'm really curious to find out.
I made this video because
Luis Tirelli asked me to.
So, if there's a topic
you'd like for me to cover
in a future Seven Ways
series, check out the link
in the description and
go and cast your vote.
I also want to give a
quick shout out to Frode
from the Actualize YouTube Channel.
Thank you so much, man, for
picking up a copy of my book,
Your One Word, and doing
the review on your channel.
I really, really appreciate
the support and I'm so glad
that you love the book.
So thank you, guys, so much for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is.
Much love.
I'll see you soon.
(dramatic sibilant music)